bonjour vous arrivé juste à temps
françois va dire une fable de jean de la
fontaine le lièvre et la tortue
rien ne sert de courir il faut partir à
point
le lièvre et la tortue en sont un
témoignage galons decency que vous
n'atteindrez points si tôt que moi
ce but si tôt etes-vous sage reparti
l'animal léger la camair il faut vous
purger avec 4 grain d'aile les bords
sajoo nous je parie encore
ainsi fut fait et de tous deux ont mis
près du but les enjeux savoir quoi ce
n'est pas la faire ni de quel juge non
content de notre lièvre n'avait que 4
passèrent j'entends de ce qu'il fait
lorsque près d'être atteint il s'éloigne
des chiens les renvoie aux calendes et
leur fait arpenter les landes ayant
dis-je du temps de reste pour brouter
pour dormir et pour écouter
d'où vient le vent laisse ma tortue
aller son train de sénateur
elle part elle s'évertue elle se bat
avec lenteur lui cependant méprise une
telle victoire tient la gageure à peu de
gloire crois qu'il y va de son honneur
de partir tard ils broutent il se repose
il s'amuse à tout autre chose qu'un la
gageure
à la fin quand il dit que l'autre
arrivait presque au bout de la carrière
il partit comme un trait mais les élans
qu'il ci furent vains la tortue arrive à
la première
et bien lui cria tél avais je pas raison
de quoi vous sert votre vitesse mois
l'emporté et que serait ce si vous pour
qu'ils aient une maison vous la
connaissiez cette fable de la fontaine
du connétable d'affronter de la
connaissait qu'est ce que ça veut dire
rien ne sert de courir il faut partir à
point
pas une petite idée tout donne un
exemple
par exemple vous avez un devoir à faire
pour l'école faut le faire au bon moment
si vous attendez si vous le faites dix
minutes avant de partir en classe
même si vous allez très vite votre
devoir sera pas finie la balle casimir
qui arrive
qu'est ce qui lui arrive et qu'on me
marche
casimir quoi qu'est ce qui t'arrive nos
vieux casque didon montebourg casimir
t'as pas l'air en grande forme ce matin
que tu est il arrivé au camp
rien de très grave j'avais simplement
inviter mes cousins barnabé théodule et
gaspard à manger à super lobby bourgain
junior
c'est une formidable idée ça casimir
alors ça c'est bien passé bien or ils
ont dû se tromper de jours ils ne sont
pas venus
et alors eh bien alors j'ai mangé le
super rugby bol car tu as tu as mangé
les trois par deux techniciens
oui tous jusqu'au dernier morceau vinci
ça et ça évidemment casimir je comprends
que ce matin du 30 plutôt lourd vous
connaissez la recette du gloubiboulga
les enfants non
je vous admire bienvenue chez vous dans
un gloubi boulga il y a de la confiture
de fraises - le chocolat en poudre de la
banane écrasée avec de la moutarde et de
la saucisse de toulouse tiède par le web
mais cruel mais crurent évidemment c'est
pas un plat très très facile à digérer
bon mes très chers amis bonjour 2009
bonjour monsieur du snob et là mais tu
m'as l'air en très mauvais état ce matin
a dit encore te goinfrer avec ton
dégoûtant gloubiboulga moi m'ont pas du
tout j'ai mangé très légèrement où je me
sens en pleine forme et effectivement je
veux bien croire que tes formes soit
pleine est ce que vous insinuez que je
suis gros eu l'impression que ça va mal
se terminer tour ne peut pas voir voilà
là là là au nom casimir non pas du tout
après avoir bien regardé je peux te dire
franchement tu n'es pas gros non tu
énorme quoi tu es incapable de bouger
aussi je suis sûr que tu ne serais pas
capable de faire dit m en courant
si vous voulez je veux bien faire
n'importe quelle course avec vous mais
je suis sûr de gagner au 15eme
c'est comme si on faisait courir je ne
sais pas avoir un lièvre mois une tortue
toi c'est ça c'est exactement comme dans
la fable de la fontaine un mot 1
on va faire une course du sco voir
insistait avant d'être à l'arrivée
nos concurrents casimir et monsieur des
snobs ont fait ce long parcours 6 et moi
c'est vous le montrer et au milieu et un
obstacle dans il tourne on une photo on
continue et voilà ça c'est le départ
tout va bien
casimir tu te sens bien je suis dans une
forme extraordinaire
parce que sans doute sur visage de galmi
ouais et alors alors attention pour un
sprint sur 10 m on dégage le départ à
boma et partez vous l'encouragez on se
met sur le parcours la mâchoire à me
regarder n'arrive même pas à marcher
mais vous monsieur duceppe lui partait
pas au moins j'ai tout le temps but je
suis si content de parler un petit peu
avec vous n'avez pas lu les facs de la
fontaine un non moins chers amis je n'y
pas de choses si facile que tout le
monde connaît non eh bien vous avez tort
parce que d'abord c'est très amusant et
ensuite vous seriez ce qui est arrivé
aux lièvres fonction casimir a gagné nom
est encore à deux mètres j'ai tout le
temps je je le rattrape et ne les fait
pas toujours ce n'est rien ne sert de
courir il faut partir à point
j'ai l'impression que nous allons avoir
une nouvelle confirmation des signes en
a plus que deux mètres à faire pour
gagner
on l'encouragé casimir avec l histoire
merci al enezi c'est vraiment gentil
d'être venus m'encourager parce que je
vais encore gagné monsieur 19 va être
furieux évite casimiro désespoir je me
dépêche
je le répète écoulé presque à rêver
tunis
allez messieurs dépêchez-vous moustique
tigre vainqueur de disney mais comment
avez vous faire aller aussi vite je n'ai
même pas autant vous dire merci aux amis
venus m'attendre dis-moi s'assurer
qu'elle est que nos problèmes que tu
voulais expliquer aux enfants
rien ne sert de partir à point quand on
est aussi gourmand que casino
ouais
[Musique]